this week on the show the coal mine
that's supposed to be closed but where
they just keep digging
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program this
week we're in merthyr tydfil home to the
country's largest open cast coal mine
and also the site of a big row with the
company here accused of operating the
mine after their permission to do so has
expired and the company saying they
won't have enough money to restore this
site when they're done well we'll come
to that a little bit later but also on
the program
an environmental bomb why Ukraine is
calling the destruction of the Nova
kakova Dam the worst environmental
disaster since Chernobyl
stay inside wear a mask if you go out
not a covid throwback but the reality
for tens of millions of Americans and
Canadians as dangerous Wildfire smog
spreads
and how this place will soon be
transformed into Britain's latest
rainforest
but first to the big scar on the hill
behind me home to the Fosse Fran mine
Britain's biggest open cast coal mine
and a source of controversy from the
moment it opened till the present day
this is Britain's biggest opencast coal
mine and it isn't supposed to be
operating anymore
but when Sky News went to film it
clearly was
fossefran in merthyr tydfil has been
extracting coal for over 15 years but
its permission to mine ran out last
September
it should have shut down on the 6th of
September last year they shouldn't be
calling anymore and they should now be
in full restoration fees
the planning consent was a 15 years and
three months of call extraction and then
to move into two to three years of
restoration and not the main basically
they've just carried on work in this
business as usual problem is the price
of call is so high at the moment it's a
license to print money I've been getting
photographs updates from people living
in the area from campaigners saying this
mining is still continuing and nobody
seems to be able to understand why it
hasn't changed well that includes me
um how come it's still operating if it's
been told to stop the basic fact of this
is our planning system is weighted in
favor of large companies it's not
weighted in favor of local communities
money gets extracted it goes to the
people who own these companies but it's
not the local area that ever benefits
and that is the history of what's
happened with mining in these values for
use if you live here you or remember
your family might work in this mine or
you might benefit from local service is
that are partly funded by the by the
money that comes from here so you might
be in support of it certainly the people
who locally have got in touch with me
are who live locally are angry that they
are being choked by these fumes in this
area they are horribly
frighteningly high levels of respiratory
disease that go back decades because of
the legacy of coal mining and and so you
know we need to be thinking of the air
that we breathe
the local authorities are aware of Fosse
Fran's continuing operation when we ask
them about what they were doing about it
merthyr tydfil Council told us they had
issued an enforcement notice the notice
requires the mining company to cease
extraction of coal from the land and
cease carrying out development at the
land other than in accordance with the
approved restoration and management
strategy the mine operator has until the
25th of July to comply failure to do so
may lead to a further escalation of
enforcement action data from the coal
Authority suggests that nearly 200 000
tons of coal have been dug since the
mine's permission ran out
most of that coal goes from here to the
Tata steelworks at Port Talbot but some
goes to power Britain's much-loved
Heritage steam trains
they like to get their black gold close
to home without positive Fran ourselves
and those other Industries are
effectively dragging coal from all
around the world from Colombia from
Australia from the US from the South
Africa
um up until Ukraine from Russia what
about the emissions from actually
dragging coal halfway around around the
world in the short term it does seem a
bit Daft when actually we could be
mining it here in the UK and an
unintended consequence of that
short-sighted decision impacts a
high-profile user massive to UK Heritage
culture in the visitor economy like
Heritage steam Railways and traction
engines and so on and so forth much of
the historical mine working here has
been restored to a semi-natural state
including this sloping pasture which was
once part of the fosifran mine but they
now say that if they have to Halt
operations they won't have the money to
landscape the rest the locals are not
amused it's our land it's mirtha common
and that it's owned by the local
Authority in effect our land where we
have rights of way on it and
um
safe access there's grazing rates on
there
what was promised to us there was no
good side to having to live by the side
of an Open Class coal mine for 15 years
other than what they promised to do at
the end of it nothing else was of any
use to us
Sky News asked the mine operators for
comment but didn't get a response but
they told Wales online that the company
is in active discussions for a safe
cessation of cooling which includes
ongoing restoration
this isn't a one-off in a country that
has declared a climate emergency to
other mines in South Wales look set to
reopen we asked the Welsh government
about Fosse Fran and the two other mines
but they didn't comment on them
specifically in a statement they
insisted that they have a planning
presumption against Mining and would
only give the go-ahead in exceptional
circumstances in the context of
decarbonization but sometimes their
hands are tied by the UK government
so might Old King Cole be about to Rise
From the Ashes the landscape that we see
it wears the scars of our history you
know some of the coal tips are still
here we are reminded every day of the
danger that those tips could actually
pose for our communities there are so
many reasons why coal mining should be
in our past it should not be in our
future
this week brought news of the
destruction of the novocarkovka dam in
Ukraine unleashing Waters from one of
the biggest reservoirs in Europe it's
caused a terrible human tragedy but as
Alex Crawford told us from her son it's
not just about the people it's harming
the environment too we're out with
another one of the relief Crews uh
they've been going on all week a number
of these rescues or delivery of supplies
have been done in the middle of an
artillery barrage or shelling we were at
a an evacuation point a number of them
as they came under Fire this has all
happened in the middle of a war zone and
you've got to remember that all this
water that you see around us is full of
sewage a large sections of it are
contaminated there was a release of
hundreds of tons of oil from the
hydroelectric plant itself there are
toxic chemicals in the water and this is
covering just in the case on region
itself something like 600 square
kilometers of land huge area swathes of
the countryside which grew agricultural
crops have been contaminated president
zelenski has called it ecocide he said
it's similar to unleashing an
environmental bomb akin to using a
weapon of mass destruction and others
have likened it to the biggest
catastrophe in this region since
Chernobyl it is likely to have a huge
impact not just short-term but long term
because this Ukraine and this area is
really the Bread Basket for the world
well I'm joined Now by Ukrainian
environment and conservation expert bud
and Pratt who's a leading member of the
National Academy of Sciences as well but
thank you very much for for joining us
tell me what do you think will be the
impact overall on the nature of this
area both above and below the dam it's
getting suddenly watered to the area
when water never been almost never been
before people suddenly got entrapped
animal got in got trapped and many of
them can easily die and then when you've
got pollution which is damn like garbage
dams or different domestic animals even
girls they can be washed away and
distributed over the area number of
animals being washed away with a water
Downstream and they now searching for
new habitats water when it's rice it
might kill them very simply because
they've wanted to find another Habitat
to me great and they will be not to do
it very quickly to find a suitable
territory the same Wetland animals like
Beaver you have seen the picture beavers
running on the street of her song he is
desperately trying to find habitats
will he find the habitats it's difficult
above the dam how big will the effect be
and how long term you've got imagines
this water reservoir is 230 kilometers
long so it's a huge huge area with with
water and they are deep somewhere up to
16 meters so it's a huge amount and then
this was area with quite well developed
over there time spawning ground and many
fish stocks and people been relaying
local economy on it on it so when water
is run away very quickly you have seen
this amount of fish which just been
laying it's just like effect the before
huge wave on the sea when it's a sea is
going away in some way and then you can
see huge number of fish laying ground
do you think this is Eco side
yes in long term it's very close
to that it's definitely when the first
impression people emotionally calling
that but when we look for the long term
and consider the size of it
an amount what we lost
I would say it's definitely
it's been a very dry early summer here
the twigs and brush are just crackling
beneath my feet but this is nothing
compared to what's going on in Canada
where prime minister Justin Trudeau has
called the early far season scary as so
many blazes are breaking out across the
country
over 400 fires are burning in almost
every Canadian province from east to
west following a warmer and drier than
average spring
meteorologists say this cluster of fires
in a remote area of Quebec was started
by lightning storms and they're causing
Thick Smoke to spread south
that blanket of smog has been shrouding
major cities on both sides of the border
with tens of millions of people living
under air quality alerts major cities
like New York Toronto Ottawa and Detroit
have at times had the worst air quality
on the planet this week with Thursday
marking the worst air quality day the US
has experienced since 2006. so what's
going on and how unusual is this
Canada is home to enormous ways of
boreal forest and is no stranger to
wildfires but the extent of the fires
and how early in the year they are is
causing alarm this graph shows the
number of hectares burnt as each of the
last eight Wildfire seasons have
progressed
over 3.5 million hectares have already
burnt in 2023 that's 13 times what's
expected by this point in the year
putting the country already on track for
its worst Wildfire season ever one
that's only just started
so what's it been like to live with that
level of smog Skye's U.S correspondent
Mark Stone sent us this report from
Philadelphia
in Philadelphia the smoke sits heavy
it's hanging and only moving slowly
across a vast part of the Northeastern
United States and this is where it's
been worst through the day at the city's
airport flights were paused for a few
hours visibility was so poor
and don't assume this is just Cloud were
it not for the smoke this would have
been a blue sky day
within the city itself though it's
harder to see that the air is quite so
bad on Rocky's steps the city officials
advice to stay indoors had not filtered
through are you worried is it overly
concern you well we did look into
getting mass that n95s this morning but
we're not that worried look actually
today looks better than yesterday even
though they said it's worse I'm being
careful they don't care so you're not
too worried sir I'm not worried I never
smoked for my life so I guess I'm
smoking a little bit but
is that you can smell and feel the
heaviness of smoke produced by wildfires
well over a thousand miles to the north
of here this is Central Philadelphia
where the air quality index was well
over 300 at one point that is hazardous
and it is record-breaking
the scale goes to 500. so this is
terrible that's what that I I don't know
how else to say that but um it just you
know just dense particulates you don't
want to breathe it in out of
Philadelphia North through New Jersey
towards New York the smoke persists
and this Manhattan time lapse shows what
New Yorkers have experienced scientists
have concluded it represents the worst
air pollution for America in recent
history
the scale of the cause the source is
just staggering from Canada's West Coast
to its East Coast forests are burning
the country is set for its worst year on
record already and we are far from being
at the peak of the season
in a time where our climate seems to be
changing so fast this is yet another
hint that the consequences of extreme
weather events impact well beyond where
they hit Mark Stone Sky News in
Philadelphia
also in the news this week labor has
u-turned on its policy to invest 28
billion pounds a year on green
Investments if it forms the next
government Shadow Chancellor Rachel
Reeves said the size of the so-called
green Prosperity plan would now only be
a Target and blamed what she said was
conservative mismanagement of the
economy the Tories had criticized the
plan as unaffordable in a week where
scientists declared an El Nino a natural
weather event likely to heat an already
warming Planet a new study predicted
that the Arctic could be free of Summer
sea ice as soon as the next decade
irrespective of how quickly we cut
emissions
it could indicate that a climate Tipping
Point has already been passed sea ice
reflects the sun's radiation but the
darker ocean absorbs it an ice-free
Arctic therefore means a faster warming
Planet new maps released this week by
the British Antarctic Survey show how
much the ice has already retreated in
both the Antarctic and the Arctic from
its average over the last 30 years shown
with the purple line down to its average
for the last 10 years shaded in purple
after the break some better news as we
hear about Devon's newest Nature Reserve
where they're hoping to revive some
native temperate rainforest and defying
expectations record numbers of puffins
Nest on a Welsh Island
[Music]
now earlier in the year we told you
about the history of temperate
rainforest in Britain and plans to
protect and expand the small fragments
that remain well now the Devon Wildlife
trust have purchased the lease on a big
stretch of land near totnes where they
plan to expand much much more of that
temperate rainforest Skies journalists
have been the first to get a look and
Dan Whitehead sent us this report
tucked away amid the sweeping moorlands
and giant talls of Dartmoor is something
very rare we're coming to the end of the
meadow now and we're just walking into
the rainforest hidden out of sight
Atlantic Woodland our answer to a
rainforest thrives there are no monkeys
swinging from trees but there is a
carbon trapping habitat-rich environment
we are in a temperate rainforest most
people have heard of tropical
rainforests like the Amazon the Congo in
Indonesia not so many people have heard
temp about temperate rainforest and why
it's a rainforest is because of the
constant high humidity and for most of
the year not today but for the most the
year very high rainfall and because of
that you don't just see trees you see
all sorts of things growing on trees so
all around us you can you can hear the
water bubbling away but every Branch
every twig you see has got Moss and
lichen growing on it
centuries of Woodland removal and
intensive agriculture have seen a huge
reduction in forests like this dense
Lush rainforest like this used to cover
around a fifth of the UK it's now
understood to be less than one percent
it's why the Devon Wildlife trust is
about to start planting a whole new one
well the outskirts of top Ness Harry and
his team will be transforming this old
Farmland into temperate rainforest
planting clusters of Oak Birch Willow
and Hazel it will take hundreds of years
and the trust says British rainforests
will cope well with our changing climate
we have to bear in mind that while
climate is changing a lot of these
forces droughts disease and things like
that they have happened in our landscape
before and most of the Native species
are quite well adapted so if we give
nature a helping hand but let nature
lead us then I think we have the best
chances of seeing this Forest survive
and thrive
the rainforest will go alongside a new
self-sufficient community on the farm
including regenerative farming and more
than 40 Eco homes the concept is that
human development doesn't necessarily
have to be negative for
um the planet we kind of I think humans
live with this sort of idea that
development is always bad but if it's
done if it's designed really really well
and carefully then it can actually have
positive impacts in terms of
biodiversity
the reintroduction of rainforest to
Devon follows similar projects in North
Wales and the Isle of Man thanks to a 38
million pound fund from Aviva even
though it will take centuries to create
environments as rich as this it is the
latest step to protect and enhance
Britain's diverse Countryside
damn why did Sky News in South Devon now
wheezed hearing stories of seabirds
under threat from climate change bird
flu or overfishing but there's one
species in one place that's doing rather
well as Lisa Morgan tells us from the
Welsh island of Scoma Scoma is the
largest sibo colony in southern Britain
it has huge numbers of Cliff nesting and
borrow nesting seabirds
one in particular that it's quite famous
for is the Puffin so Atlantic puffins
breed here on Scoma in large numbers
spring in March when our wardens counted
the population here just before the
start of the season and before Birds go
underground when we can't see them they
counted 42 000 individual birds which is
the largest count we've had post second
world war so it's a really incredible
number of puffins and an increasing
population
Scoma is quite unusual in that it's
bucking the trend of puffing populations
just about everywhere else in their
range where they're really struggling
and declining
can see all the Burrows around us here
puffins breed underground in Burrows and
so they're very vulnerable to Predators
on land Scoma doesn't have any and
predators so there are no rats no foxes
Stokes weasels hedgehogs nothing like
that here which has allowed these
populations to increase so dramatically
so we're very conscious of um the
introduction of an invasive species
especially a brown raft which would be
disastrous for the birds here
[Music]
a devastating impact on sibo colonies
around the UK we haven't had any
positive cases here on Sky Morris gocum
but we have had cases nearby on on the
Grasso Island organetri which sits off
the pembranger coast very close to Scoma
Island
so that's something we're very conscious
of and we're very mindful of
that's all for this show we'll be back
next week here in the Surrey Hills which
believe it or not is the latest Frontier
in a battle over oil and gas drilling
remember you can catch up on all your
climate and environment news on the Sky
News website and app or by scanning the
QR code that's just appeared on the
screen
bye for now
[Music]